so here at home brian we also have
reaction from people right in our
community
who were watching the verdict as it was
read madison kimbrough joining us live
from downtown las vegas with some of
those folks in that local reaction
yeah today was a monumental day for
george floyd his family
and the country as a verdict was read
and the country
announced and saw that former
minneapolis police officer david chavin
was convicted of murder and manslaughter
the explosive case triggered worldwide
protest and violence
including right here in las vegas i
spoke to people in the downtown las
vegas area right after the verdict was
read
here's what they had to say i'm happy
with it i'm glad
i hope that the family gets some closure
with this
it's deliberate i say he killed him
i wanted to go through the screen i
couldn't believe that
nobody did anything nobody stopped
i don't care what floyd did he didn't
deserve that
you may have been watching coverage in
some other cities as there have been
peaceful gatherings around both before
and after the verdict was read so far no
reports of any rallies
at this moment but we are hearing plans
for a peaceful gathering happening later
this evening
near the venetian here on the strip so
we'll keep a lookout for that reporting
live madison kimbrough 8 news now